dr karl weiss est avec nous bonsoir dr
weiss je vous montre le tableau de la
journée pour le québec avec le taux
d'hospitalisation aux 6,4 pour cent ça
bouge peu près pas depuis des jours et
des jours soins intensifs la même chose
on a beaucoup parlé du malheur des
sièges sld de l'autre côté est ce que
vous continuez à dire que c'est une très
bonne nouvelle que les hôpitaux désignés
ne déborde pas oui c'est une très bonne
nouvelle on voit dans les hôpitaux je
vous dirais on a réussi a quand même
tenir je vous dirais la l'assaut de la
vad
donc on a pas eu d hospitalisation
débridée on n'a pas eu des débordements
des soins intensifs
oui à une augmentation et eu beaucoup
plus de travail est habituellement c'est
un hôpital complètement différent de ce
qu'on voit habituellement dans tous les
hôpitaux qui sont pris avec les cas de
comics 19 mais je vous dirais le québec
a réussi certainement je tirais son pari
au niveau des hôpitaux de façon générale
à maintenir le système à flot
et comme on l'a dit à plusieurs reprises
chez les ch et celle d où la bataille se
joue c'est les centres de soins
prolongés les résidences pour personnes
âgées etc
c'est là où évidemment on voit
actuellement que le nombre de décès
malheureusement élevé est aussi bon on a
encore des cas on est encore dans une
phase il est assez actif du nombre de
cas surtout quand on teste pas tout le
monde
alors les gens contestent on voit qu'on
a quand même neuf cent mille cas par
jour nouveau ce auditionne donc on est
quand même temps et c'est sûr que c'est
seulement le la pointe de l'iceberg dont
on sait qu'il ya encore de la
transmission intense et c'est rare mais
ça n'a pas d'impact sur l'utilisation
des délits dans les soins aigus
c'est une cascade évidemment il ya les
cas d'abord ensuite les hospitalisations
et ensuite malheureusement pour
plusieurs les décès alors on ne faut pas
s'attendre n'est ce pas ce qu'est une
baisse des décès significative tant qu
est pas une baisse du nombre de cas en
amont
tout à fait surtout au niveau des soins
prolongés des chsct
il ya des patients malheureusement qui
vont encore baisser dès vous savez c'est
comme un peu il faut s'imaginer c'est
comme une roue qui a été lancé vous
savez vous allés l'arrêter mais vous
n'allez pas l'arrêter net de la roue va
prendre un certain temps vous allez
devoir la retenir pendant un certain
temps pour qu'elle arrête son mouvement
alors c'est un petit peu ça si vous
voulez son espèce de no de balancier qui
a été envoyée qu'on va ralentir
on va arrêter mais on peut pas l'arrêter
instantanément très bien dr vince
quelques questions du public
l'information a circulé à l'effet que
les hommes seraient plus à risque
d'attraper la maladie l'avait de
développer des complications est ce le
cas alors en réalité il ya plus d'hommes
hospitalisé que de femmes
et il ya eu plus de décès chez les
hommes que chez les femmes faut aussi
savoir que des fois les hommes ont plus
des facteurs confondants qui sont des
facteurs de risques que les femmes dont
quand on parle par exemple des problèmes
de maladies pulmonaires cardiaques
diabète etc donc souvent il y avait cet
aspect là mais il ya eu aussi la
discussion que au point de vue génétique
les femmes mais vous savez c'est au
point de vue militaire les femmes sont
le sexe fort depuis c'est connu la en
médecine depuis longtemps les femmes ont
tendance à avoir moins de mortalité pour
des causes par exemple de maladies
infectieuses fulminantes et aigus que
les hommes et ça c'est vrai dès la
naissance ainsi si vous prenez des
hommes décidés garçons dans made man qui
a façonné des enfants qui ont tout au
long de la vie donc les femmes sont le
sexe fort au point de vue dix militaires
et donc il ya peut être un aspect aussi
génétique qui fait que les hommes ont
fondé maladie plus sévère entre
guillemets que les femmes mais il ya
d'autres facteurs confondants sont le
tabac le diabète l'obésité les maladies
cardiaques et c'est n'est pas juste en
médecine d'ailleurs pour le sexe fort
est-ce que la tente mais la
transpiration est un vecteur de
transmission au même site que les
gouttelettes de la bouche et du nez
non pas du tout alors la transmigration
c'est pas une façon de transmettre le
virus s'adapte donc des films traitement
non
je saute à la question 4 si le virus a
besoin d'un autre une cellule vivante on
l'a beaucoup expliqué pour se reproduire
comment se forme alors la toute première
c'est une question presque philosophique
une question philosophique celle s est
créé la vie
alors écoutez là vous poser une question
je serai certainement pas capable de
répondre il faut savoir par contre c'est
que je vais peut être dire dans cette
affaire à cette question là que les gens
disent on a un virus qui a été créé en
laboratoire on peut pas créer un virus
en laboratoire on peut prendre des virus
les modifier on peut essayer
d'introduire des gènes des games n'ont
pas créé un virus parce que créer un
virus et créer la vie on est en état des
des années lumières de la capacité de
créer la vie dans l'humanité
actuellement de 7 500 l'a donc de
synthétiser un virus à partir de rien là
on n'est pas capable de faire ça ouais
c'est ça parce que là vous faites
référence aux rumeurs là que ça ça
serait ça serait issu d'un laboratoire
chinois là où on aurait alors pour
l'instant ce qui est possible c'est que
dans un laboratoire où les conditions de
travail de sécurité n'étaient pas
adéquats et il n'y avait pas je vous
dirais d un comportement de façon très
réglementée de la fin des gens qui
travaillaient qu'un virus avec lequel
ont travaillé dans ses laboratoires
s'est retrouvé dehors en du confinement
d'accord ça c'est possible mais de créer
le virus ça c'est une autre histoire
très bien 2 2 très rapide question de
temps avec l'arrivée de l'été
que faire des systèmes de climatisation
et de ventilation ya pas de problème
vous allez voir je finis toujours par
une question d'un enfant matteo je sais
pas quel âge at il et est ce que le
virus a des pattes
si je lis sur un bras est-ce qu'il peut
remonter jusqu'à mon et non la façon
dont il ya pas de pattes et mais par
contre ce qu'il ya c'est que on peut le
déplacer d'avancé si gelé sur mon bras
je touche mon bras et puis après ça jo
touche le néo richepin transportés s'est
pourtant c'est important de ne pas se
toucher la face de façon continuelle et
de faire attention de bien se laver les
mains à ce sont des mecs
sont nos vecteurs de ce virus là alors
il n'y a pas de pattes mais est capable
se déplacer avec nos mains très bien je
vous a juste une petite dernière il
reste un peu de temps combien de virus
on avale quand on est à contacter l avec
le virus 4 c 5 millions souvent on parle
de millions de vies riom savoir qu'un
virus est extrêmement petit on parle de
souvent de deux dixièmes de millionième
de micros donc c'est c'est tout petit ça
prend donc des millions particules qui
vont souvent nous infectés alors on ya
beaucoup de virus qui nous a fait quand
on l'a à dr weiss merci beaucoup bonne
fin de semaine à vous vos tirages pour
la suite
au revoir alors on revoit tout le monde
3 voir
merci au revoir